if you love names and you know if I'm
ear handsome if you tell me and you love
it clap your hands if you love means and
you know and you really want to show it
if you tell means and you know it clap
your hands
YouTube's favorite show everybody meme
review welcome to PewDiePie the number
one for tonight compilation clip channel
on YouTube if you're enjoying this video
right now and want some B bucks go ahead
and leave a like and hit that Bell
button I'm your host Felix Kjellberg
let's begin reviewing the memes this
meme is blowing up lately guys my god
I've been seeing it left and right and I
don't think honestly I don't think I've
laughed a single time while seeing it
but I'm not supposed to put my own
opinion in theme review that's not what
this is about car salesman slaps roof of
car this bad boy can fit so much but get
it get it now of course you do of course
you do why why wouldn't this be funny
really anything is a meme these days car
salesman slaps roof on car this baby can
fit so much ah yo did you see that
spider hanging off the mirror yeah I'm
out yo I quit
okay moderately funny I'll admit it's
the kind of jokes that makes you go
that's funny
instead of actually my thing that's so
funny car salesman slaps car now that's
a lot of damage fine you know what this
one gets a pace because I want Phil to
slap me just like he slaps that card
slaps the roof of keyboard put a little
that's so funny steam summer sales
slap steam account this bad boy can fit
so many unplayed games in it that's
funny because it's true car salesman car
fine you made one laughs congratulations
car salesman slaps customer you're it
salesman beats dead horse this mean
thank you at least people realize you
know what I'm gonna slap the roof of
this meat and I'm gonna read it a one
cuz I wanted to die it's not funny okay
can we put can at least a decent mean
make it to mean review thank you leave
you after you have defeated love pump
after you defeated little Sam you've
been taking that little yachty after you
have taken out hex
oh no back to you have taken now 21 this
guy shows up and it's a fight to the
death
you know how sound my rappers got a
reputation for being loud and obnoxious
and over-the-top this guy okay I'll do
that
but I'll crank it up a hundred sorry a
thousand you know we named anime how
they always having another boss you
think like this is the last bus this is
it and then there's another one who the
hell would be above six nine okay what
kind of monstrosity with that beat I
don't even want to think about it scares
me now if you don't know who this is you
just don't worry about it
there's plenty of clues here there's a
six nine okay alright six nine yeah okay
and there's six nine and sixteen then
six nine six nines I know I'm not sure
either I'm trying to figure out where
this is coming from let's see here okay
so yeah keep holding up your arms I can
see through six nine oh it's just this
little Aussie fella that I've been
hearing so much about
is that him now I'm not gonna show his
music honestly he gets a lot of bad rip
but I don't hate it
music I'm not going to show it mainly
for the reason that it will get copied
striped so we'll just show this parody
instead which is actually not supposed
to be a parody which in itself is
hilarious you may know him from this
wonderful clip jewelry but we're gonna
hear tests you know real diamond yo
Jimmy come in let's do it
he just got lucky I love that antelope's
tarik I'm given stone bro I feel like
this is fake but at the same time you
seemed genuinely embarrassed so who
knows now a lot of people hate on my boy
Takeshi for one reason one reason only
because he pled guilty on the felony
count of a use of a child in a sexual
performance I have that footage and I'm
going to show it so please if you have
sensitive ice close to right now are you
ready oh how could you how could you I
always look up to SoundCloud rappers
that's where
pick get my morals my ideas my
inspiration and if I can glow and if I
can't look up the tech kc6 now then who
do I have
who do I have you have forgotten who you
are if you're not careful
Takeshi could he runs extremely fast
arguably faster than keemstar
[Applause]
six nine
but he has a warm heart you know he
might be me but he's also lean but most
of all he like an underage teen he'll
come from anywhere be prepared
this guy has mastered the game
[Music]
this guy from New York City he just
drove more than 50 miles in the rain sex
with someone he thinks is a 12 year old
drunk this meme gets an inconclusive
that's right everybody would love to see
more 6-9 memes there's just not enough
of them I got this trick walk okay these
men right here do you know them do you
know them the next meme is none other
than the overwatch hamster so cute
finally a hamster in the overwatch
community it's such a wide range of
characters they have literally any one
but we have not yet seen a hamster
finally a video game character then I
could personally relate to how else am I
going to enjoy a video game unless I can
relate to the character in every single
way now some people okay not all but
some people were mad about the hamster
saying we asked for a single black woman
and this is what you do excuse me are
you assuming this mystique of the
hamster tumbler head tumbler had a lot
to say about this hamster overwatch
officially has more fur sonís in it than
LGBT people like that sinking that's
right everybody let that sink in mmm I
know there are definitely things to be
upset about here hey Blizzard we want a
black female character confirms an
irrelevant ass hamster as a playable
character excuse me excuse me
irrelevant dude users call the hamster
in overwatch irrelevant I understand
this is definitely things worth being
upset about and I will rate this meme
it's not really a mean I just like
people being upset I don't care what
they're upset about as long as people
are upset it makes me happy so 10 out of
10 baby we did it the overwatch hamster
gets a 10 out of 10 next me no it's not
a bonus mean no it's not a bonus means
stop stop sit down sit down
do not oppose me what does it mean is
dead damn it
just another mean sorry this meme means
a little bit of context everybody
there's this wonderful clip of this guy
complaining that a passenger is eating a
burrito you can't wait
science has no meaning you're drinking
you don't get it you don't get it
you must be stupid you've seen people
like him on TV yes get the police tap
that man in his burrito at lunch which
leads to this to me
I love this maybe it generally makes me
happy for some reason it was supposed to
be in your life you lose but Brad just
caught it out what the Frick Brad
there's also the clip of the girls
selling water illegally there's these
eight-year-old girls and then the mom
calls her out she called police on an
eight-year-old little girl you hide all
you want the whole world don't see you
boo on my property selling water Holt
send the nukes I think my favorite one
however is the charcoal lady who calls
the cop because they're grilling with
charcoal what's going on she doesn't
want to talk now no it's not actually
I'm calling the cops
these are the heroes these are the real
superhero
[Music]
who are you gonna play for the new smash
game permit patty or barbecue Betty your
native your name is jr. and you're
really handsome come on raise your hand
oh my gosh
hey get size seven but it has potential
okay I might do a mean correction if
this one gets more and finally the most
important news of the whole world we won
in the case of European Union versus me
the European Union try to try to pass a
law that said you can't post memes
anymore
European Union rejects meme been for a
now it's a big win but the battle is far
from over
basically they're gonna vote again in
September so we need to keep fighting
more European memes needs to happen we
fight memes with memes we fight fire
with fire this has been meme review
YouTube's most important show of all the
time please go ahead and leave a like a
thumbs up and I'll see you guys tomorrow